[Music]
okay how do I increase my understanding
of AI Beyond off-the-shelf packages I've
got the answer to that one you have to
build things I mean many of the most
capable AI practitioners just put effort
into building things for themselves
reimplementing things you know one great
example of that that a for PhD grad is
Andre Kathy so Andre has had a career
first working at Tesla and now he's back
at open AI but you know he's also just a
weekend hacker who likes to build things
and the reality is that just by building
things for yourself from scratch even if
they replicate something that someone
has done or a big framework from a tech
company you just learn so much and
that's always a great exercise to work
through okay
what are some promising new career paths
within
AI so there are a lot right we're still
at a stage in which there's just a huge
shortage of machine learning engineers
and a huge shortage of people with a
good understanding of newal networks
natural language processing and Robotics
and related Technologies so if you get
good skills in these areas there are all
sorts of things that you can do every
kind of industry whether you're thinking
the car industry people in banking and
finance people in construction people
who' like to automate mining or
agriculture anywhere you look there are
ways that you could use artificial
intelligence to reinvent different
Industries okay I've completed the
basics of machine learning and deep
learning what should I learn next um I
don't think that's a question that has a
one siiz fits all answer one answer is
find a project that's something that
you're really interested in it could be
something at work or it could just be
something that's completely an interest
of yours as a hobbyist thing so spending
more time actually building AI
application from beginning to end is
still a huge um further learning
exercise after doing one or two of our
classes but there are lots of other
great classes you could do and I think
at that point it depends more on what
you're interested
[Music]
in